je voudrais dire le confinement c'est
une destruction sanitaire parce qu'à
tous les gens pas soigné de d'autres
maladies c'est une destruction sociale
écologique économique absolument
monstrueuse c'est dramatique ce qui se
passe donc trois fois de suite le pays
ne s'en relèvera pas donc il faut
bloquer éviter le confinement et je vais
vous donner trois exemples et je vais
vous faire sourire et malheureusement
c'est grave quand je suis venu la
dernière fois chez nous il ya un an j'ai
demandé le contrôle des frontières
j'ai parlé de l'asie j'ai dit voilà ce
qui se passe en asie
voilà ce qu'ils font ils bloqueraient
frontières ils font des thèses
quarantaine et tout si on veut régler le
problème il faut peut-être confinement
mais il faut bloquer les frontières
tous vous m tomber dessus c'est pas les
mêmes qu'un pan tout le monde m'est
tombé dessus on m'a fait passer pour les
fascistes le dingue
pendant des mois j'ai réclamé le
contrôle des frontières
on m'a dit c'est pas possible le premier
ministre le ministre moody du point il
n'y aura pas non
ils y viennent mais ils le font pas ils
ne font pas bien la solution pour éviter
à terme un confinement interpété c'est
de contrôler les frontières je préfère
est enfermé dans mon pays est enfermé à
domicile parce que c'est ça le choix mes
journées pour laisser ce qui se passe en
asie l'économie brillance et en asie
nouveau resto lavier connais mon live on
l'a tous marchent parce qu'ils ont eu le
courage de dire on rentre pas mais nous
ya l'idéologie sans frontières y sont
rentrés le et c'est pas possible
deuxième pour aller dire celles d'hawaï
oui c'est deuxième point parce que c'est
grave ça c'est que je veux qu'on passe
d'une logique de protection des
personnes en danger
plutôt que d'en fermer toute la france
et je vous donne un exemple
jallet a mené le masque ffp2 ce masque
ffp2 j'ai été invité comme chef de parti
à toutes les réunions
interministérielles ddi réunion
interministérielle premiers ministres
ministres ou le bazar et tous à chaque
fois je leur dit combien de masques ffp2
vous commandez quand est-ce que vous en
donnez aux personnes âgées
quand est ce que vous les distribuer aux
personnes vulnérables 15 millions de
personnes vulnérables
on sait pas on sait pas et tout à la fin
monsieur véran me dit on peut pas madame
merkel madame merkel anglais ang et là
elle a envoyé à 27 millions de foyers de
personnes âgées un lot de 15 masques
ffp2 vous pouvez avoir un confinement
demain la petite personne âgée qui la
messe que masque en tissu
qui protège pas équivalent à déverser
cours on a dit que ça serait une
catastrophe le maïs on attendait qu'elle
va quand même mal gagne confinement
aller acheter son paquet de brad une
fois par semaine elles risquent beaucoup
plus que s'il ya pas de confinement et
qu'elle a masc afellay jusqu'à 12x et
plus dont il y en a ras-le-bol alors ce
chantage là je vous le dis très
clairement ce chantage permanent si vous
êtes contre le confinement est
d'enfermer tous les français c'est que
vous êtes un horrible bonhomme qui veut
tuer les gens je ne l'acceptent plus il
ya plus d excuse et le troisième point
où je dis qu'il faut protéger n'a pas
fait les trois pôles encore il y en a
deux frontières et une troisième à ce qu
on protections ciblées d'accord parce
que il faut protéger les gens qui
risquent quelque chose est sûre c'est ce
que dakar est évident et et dernier
point le troisième point est là c'est de
soigner les français parce que l'on va
m'expliquer pourquoi ce que vous avez
enlevé maxine et vous attendez pourquoi
ce gouvernement n'en moi mon âge encore
chez limites
non ça va on y va mais s'il va sûrement
pas mort ça va être votre je vais vous
répondre après un temps d avance avec 20
à vous je suis pas dans un débat e
business
mais avant je reviens sur les soins
pourquoi se fait-il qu'en france le
ministre de la santé refuse des études
indépendantes sur tous les soins
possibles ivermectine l'ivermectine est
et l'analyser mais il utilisé par les
réanimateurs j'en ai rencontré hier
l'ivermectine imaginez on utilise juste
l'ivermectine a pas le droit d'utiliser
en médecine de ville envoie l'argument
c'est un argument encore les soigner les
gens moi ce que j'aimerais qu'ils
finissent en réanimation n'est pas l'or
n'a pas le droit oui mais eux mais on
n'est pas là on trouvera des solutions
la somalie et nous reste ce qu'elle est
il faut s'unir dans les chaufferies fiel
je trouvais mais enfermé et donc vous
n'êtes pas pour l'autre sur lui pour
tout éviter par des frontières des
masses
oui mais c'est trop tard trop tard mais
je vais vous dire une chose on va fermer
le pays on va vous mettre sous terre
pendant combien d'années à chaque
variant on va dire il ya des grands
professeurs lara qui vont nous dire on
peut pas il ya d'autres solutions
il ya des pays qui vivent les pays qui
m'émeut
attention je suis pas pour être là que
si je ne nie pas l'épidémie je ne nie
pas les difficultés
je ne nie pas les morts mais quand est
ce qu'on va protéger les personnes
vulnérables dont il croyait au vaccin
vous y croyez ou pas de vaccin ça dépend
du vaccin n'y croyais pas alors je me
sens bien sur le ballon je suis franc le
vaccin classique qu'ont utilisés les
chinois me
c'est beaucoup plus sûr que le vaccin
arn où on n'a pas de regret a vu qu'en
israël on vaccine mais ma tête et moi
j'attends page 22 du protocole files
heures j'en ai sur moi pas soldé sur moi
y'a marqué quoi que études l'étude
continue jusqu'à fin 2020 alors ça alors
du bitume de la réallocation monsieur
fisher je finis juste monsieur fisher ce
monsieur qui dit à monsieur fillon sur
rtl
american extraordinaire dans ce pays iny
sur rtl monsieur fisher avanthier la
deuxième radio de france
oui oui il dit quoi je ne sais pas si ce
vaccin protège de plus de trois mois et
je ne fais pas ci s'empêche de
transmettre de toute façon même s'il
marche et qu'il est génial et je le
souhaite
alors on est sous l'eau mais il marche
le choix de tous pendant neuf mois il
suffira pas ils sont pas capables de le
livrer donc il faudra peut-être protéger
les français masques frontières soins et
si on fait ça on peut dire ah mais très
vite et on peut peut-être été le
confinement